pour célébrer ces 10 ans la maison des
parents de Trapp avait organisé une
journée de jeux et détente au programme
cache-cache cour et jeux de société
ouvert toute l'année cet établissement
propose de nombreuses activités
gratuites pour parents et enfants il y a
beaucoup d'activités pour les familles
de manière générale à trrappe la maison
des parents on est une parmi d'autres et
ce qui est bien c'est ça commence tout
petit on avait commencé avec mon plus
grand euh à faire de la baby gym pour la
motricité le centre se veut aussi un
lieu d'écoute pour les parents ont
difficultés ceux-ci peuvent consulter
différents médecins pour leurs enfants
ou eux-mêmes de façon anonyme et
gratuite j'ai déjà eu à à faire à la
psychologue j'avais un moment passager
au niveau santé pour un enfant et j'ai
eu besoin de voir laapsy et ils
arrangent toujours pour faire au plus
vite quand ils sentent l'urgence et et
j'étais contente de pouvoir en
bénéficier cette maison au fait
s'adresse comme je vous l'ai dit à tout
parent par rapport à un besoin
spécifique un parent à un moment donné
se pose des questions d'inquiétude de
voir par rapport à son enfant par
rapport à son adolescence surtout à la
crise d'adolescence qui peut être
quelque chose banale en soi mais qui
peut angoisser le parent et ben il peut
avoir accès à une rencontre avec une
psychologue clinicienne par exemple la
mairie souhaite poursuivre les activités
sur le long terme de ce lieu qui
s'inscrit dans sa politique de lutte
contre l'échec scolaire et la
délinquence